on capitol hill a clear majority of
house republicans
voted to remove congresswoman liz chaney
from her leadership post yesterday
after she repeatedly denounced former
president trump and his
false claims that the last election was
stolen republican jim jordan one of the
former president's most loyal
allies in congress spoke with chief
washington correspondent major garrett
about the vote and the future of the gop
do me a favor and define what
conservatism is now
we are an american first party
uh a populist party rooted in
conservative principle
can you be a conservative and disagree
with the president about the 2020
election
well i think i don't think it's it's
it's uh helpful i think we should be
focused on
um making sure that we have integrity in
our elections going forward that's what
i've always said about
there are millions of americans who have
concerns about what happened in this
last election i've never said this
election was stolen
all i've said is let's check it out
those concerns originate with their own
organic knowledge or because they hear
president trump say over and over and
over it was stolen from him
it originated with them of course it did
trump had nothing to do with that
well all i'm saying is 80 million
americans instinctively know whether
regardless of what president trump may
or may not have said
they know well think about it i think
maybe to reassure the american people 80
million of them
both republicans and democrats who have
those concerns why not look into it
that's all i've said all along
but somehow oh that's crazy you can't do
that makes so much sense to me
courts election officials and the former
president's own justice department
looked into the 2020 election and found
no
evidence to overturn the result in any
state and yet
mr trump continues to tell his
supporters the election
was a fraud the undisputed leader of the
republican party is
president trump for how long um i think
he's going to run again
and i'm all for that i
will do everything i can to ensure
uh that uh the former president never
again gets anywhere near the oval office
when you can't have the republican
conference chair the republican party
spokesperson
consistently attacking the leader of the
party who 74 million americans
voted for in your party there's a large
conversation about cancel culture
has liz cheney been cancelled i've never
called for her
step down and and excuse me resigned
from congress i do think there's a big
difference though
between whether you're going to be in
congress or not and
us deciding as republicans in congress
who's going to be our spokesperson
trump has described cheney as a war
monger and yesterday called her a bitter
horrible human being is liz cheney a
bitter
horrible human being
look i've worked with liz uh i've said
all along that i don't think she should
be conference chair i was i was
you know what i'm driving at the former
president has language that is highly
personal at times
and insulting do you agree with any of
it in regards to liz cheney
well i think in this situation uh liz
has said some things about the president
i think it's probably
um elevated the the the rhetoric a
little bit
and sometimes he comes back that's
that's human nature i understand that
it's very sad yeah it is it's very very
sad to me what has happened to liz taney
that for telling the truth
something we all teach our children we
you tell the truth
she tells the truth and she is greatly
penalized for it
now there seems to be revisionist
history here in the republican party and
dare i say some selective amnesia about
what was said and what wasn't said well
i mean
to mr to congressman jordan's point that
this should be looked at it has been
the election should be looked at it has
been looked at it was taken to
i think 60 courts all of whom said
there's nothing here
and what's fascinating is elise stefanik
who will replace liz cheney presumably
has a much more moderate record of
voting in congress than liz cheney who
voted pretty much locked up with
president trump
no history is watching it will be
interesting to see how this all plays
out because i don't think it's over yet